I think it's a distraction because I
mean it's true in the sense that the
hippocampus is necessary to have a
conscious recollection of some past
event and the amygdala participates in
unconscious memory but we shouldn't
really taint it with the Freudian
concepts because that adds a lot of
baggage the amygdala is is an
unconscious processor because it's just
not connected with the conscious system
it's kind of like you know by default
unconscious as opposed to being in the
14 sense of unconscious something that
was conscious but was to
anxiety-provoking and therefore ship to
the unconscious the amygdala gets direct
sensory information and it learns and
stores information on its own and that
information that's stored then controls
emotional responses the connectivity is
hardwired so one way to think about it
is that a rat will respond to a cat
without any learning by freezing raising
its blood pressure and heart rate and
respiration and releasing stress
hormones but it was also it will also
respond to a stimulus associated with
the cat and have the same responses so
you don't learn how to be afraid you
don't your mig doula doesn't have to
learn what to do it learns what to do it
in response to so it learns what stimuli
it should respond to so it's learning
and memory in that sense that we call an
implicit kind of memory where you don't
have to have any conscious involvement
whereas the hippocampus is necessary to
have a conscious memory so yes there
they do participate in conscious and
unconscious memories but not in the
Freudian sense but there's a whole other
side of the amygdalas role in memory
which is that when the amygdala is
activated and all those hormones and
other things happen they get released
that provides information that feeds
back to parts of the brain like the
hippocampus and allows them to store
their their memories in a much more
efficient and strong way so we know that
emotional memories are stored more
vividly
than other kinds of memories it used to
be thought that they were they're more
accurate but in fact now we know they're
not more accurate that this sort of more
vivid and strong in the personal sense
but they can be highly inaccurate this
is this is shown by studies of natural
disasters and so forth well not always
so natural but like the space challenge
air shot you know the the the shovel
space shuttle Challenger explosion a lot
of people witnessed that and the they
were studied and almost immediately by
psychologists who made notes of exactly
what their response is you know what
they were what what they were
experiencing at the time and then a year
later they were surveyed again and the
responses were completely different from
what they remembered originally and then
several years later it completely
changed again so what we remember is not
necessarily what we experienced
originally so that the accuracy of those
memories changes over time but their
strength in terms of your subjective
feeling that it was a really powerful
experiences there